albania has taken a major step toward
european union membership
the general affairs council has decided
to grant the western balkans country
candidate status
subject to approval by eu leaders but
the council's urging albania to step up
the fight against corruption
and organize crime and do more to help
relieve
immigration pressures on the union once
its candidacy is endorsed by eu leaders
tirana will await a date for
negotiations to begin on the lengthy
process
of bringing its legislation into line
with european standards
or a key stella
we are sending a message of friendship
and cooperation to albania
the albanian government and political
system says the greek eu presidency
we're sure that our albanian friends
understand that there's a legal and
institutional framework of reference
the copenhagen political criteria the
respect for the eu a key
and
in other developments the council
adopted a new european
maritime security strategy the strategy
protects europe's interests against
threats and risks in the global maritime
area given the eu's dependence on the
sea for trade
economic development fisheries tourism
and energy security
the ministers also made preparations for
the summit of eu leaders
the european council to be held in the
belgian town of
ipa on june 26th to mark the centenary
of world war one
and in brussels the following day the
main topics are the eu's area of freedom
security and justice economic growth and
jobs
and climate change and energy security
leaders will also consider developments
on the next president
of the european commission they'll sign
agreements on closer ties and trade
so-called association agreements
with georgia moldova and ukraine as well